hey everybody it's mike from order flows
and welcome to today's uh quick video on
you know some of the interesting things
that i saw in the order flow this
morning now it is uh september 12 2022
and you know what i want to talk about
again is touching on delta and how uh
you can see absorption by watching the
order flow delta
now you know today we had a nice rally
since about 7 30. you could see here the
730 is right here we rallied up from you
know the 95
and a quarter area all the way up uh i
think it was 37 and a quarter was the
high started come off i mean right now
where are we trading here we're trading
um you know back up at 29 but we did
pull back to this sort of cash open
level around uh you know five and a half
cash opened up in here you know right
around this so seven area so we did get
that pullback and then uh sort of
rallying back up i'm not sure i mean who
knows where this market is we'll
probably will take out those highs late
in the day but we're sort of coming back
up towards the high
now
what i want to talk about is you know
signs in
signs of absorption and how you could
recognize it in the order flow now
i always say you know a general rule of
thumb and i say general because it's not
always the case is you know as a market
is rallying it's going to rally with
positive delta if a market is selling
off you're going to see negative delta
you'll see red bars with negative deltas
on moves down on markets that are
rallying i see green bars with positive
delta why because you know as the market
is going up everyone's
being aggressive they're lifting the
offers they're buying buying buying just
as if um the markets are selling off
everyone is selling they're hitting the
bids market is dropping however
what you
like to see
you don't always see it but this gives
you that extra boost or if you will you
know the extra confirmation
that the move has strength to it is
signs of absorption and what that means
is supportive buying on moves up or
resistant selling on moves down and on
today's rally
very early we're seeing it right what we
had here just
around 843 you know starting to rally up
test these highs and you've got one bar
two bars with negative delta right green
bars markets going up negative delta
and again over here
you got an
um another bar right here negative delta
minus 193
okay and people will say well you know
why markets may know what's up with this
order flow crap you know
markets shouldn't be going up on
negative delta you got aggressive
selling well yeah you do have that
aggressive selling but it's being
absorbed by strong passive buyers
remember markets trade in a two-way
auction there's a buyer there's a seller
it's when somebody crosses
that
bid offer
that a trade happens
now
when markets go up people are buying the
offer right that's aggressive buying
right they're lifting the offer but what
you want to see is because you do have
two-way money two-way trading right you
got buying and selling if you see a big
bid come in
to absorb whatever selling is coming in
what do you think the market's telling
you it's telling you there's support
forming in the market
okay
now it might be a little bit hard for
some people to pick that up on a
footprint charge because there's a lot
of numbers and oh numbers i'm scared
but
look at simply just look at the delta
okay i got a green candle with negative
delta
maybe i should look deeper at this right
see oh it's got minus 150
okay what what's going on here well i
see in the 2a auction here at 12 12 and
a quarters 419 traded on the bid versus
294.
okay what's that telling me that's
telling me that there's some supportive
buying coming in here then i could look
deeper i could see oh yeah there's 400
here there's 500 traded at this price
there's 381 there's 349 okay yeah i got
some strong buying coming in even up
here at 167 against 81 right that's
about another
80 contract difference in the delta
right and
in this next bar up here i mean you can
see it here 403 versus 322 388 versus
274 309 versus 243 um 300 versus 122.
okay
see the strong negative delta look a
little bit deeper into the green candle
what's going on
why is it got negative delta okay well i
see strong passive buyers are coming in
you know the if you look on a delta
footprint you know it starts to get a
little bit
easier a little bit clearer
right you can see here right you can see
the delta minus 143
minus 193 now these are horizontal
deltas delta at price but i know that
if i have strong
volume at a price level and it's on the
bid side it's telling me that there were
strong passive buyers here i've got
minus 171 minus 60 minus 35 minus 57. i
mean look at this bar this whole bottom
half is strong support of buying just as
here strong support of buying
and that's the sign that you want to
look for right i mean these bars are
trading decent volume four thousand
contracts four thousand
you know here's three thousand
but that's a sign of absorption is those
negative deltas on as the market is
rallying because what's happening is
somebody's coming into the market and
bidding they want to hold this market up
now you know these execution algos that
are out there from you know the
different banks have that they give to
their um you know to their customers
they have these fancy execution algos
and you know they're smart enough to
know that they're just not going to go
in and start lifting every single offer
if they got a lot of buying what they'll
do is they'll put some on the bed
they'll be monitoring the offer if the
offer starts trading you know maybe
they'll buy some on the offer
you know or bump their bid up etc you
know but those whole the whole execution
algo business is about trying to get as
much of a position on without moving the
market or having you know any sort of
market impact
but it shows up in the footprint right i
could see that there was strong buying
in here on the bid side strong passive
buying and if i have that strong passive
buying when the market pulls back into
it if i'm identifying this as strong
passive buying and the market starts
pulling back i'm looking for this to
hold
and it did over the next two bars it
pulled back into it a little bit you can
see this red bar it pulled back down
into 12
but my my area is between 11 and a half
up to you know 12 and a quarter up here
or is it here um again i'm looking
between you know 15 and a quarter and
the low at 14 where i see the strong
bidding in market went up pulled back
pulled back just to 15 and a quarter
right so i know that this support area
is holding i know that this support area
is holding
in this move higher right and that's
what you like to see because you know as
the market is moving up and up and up
right generally you're going to see bars
like this where it's just all the offers
are just being lifted up with impunity
right right here but as you're going
higher now you start to see this is
where it gets interesting
new highs
and you've seen strong support of
bidding coming in here minus 137 minus
230. you know on the footprint it wasn't
as clear because there was some decent
volume coming in there
um where was that that was uh over here
right you can see the 812 versus 154
this is a nice big imbalance but you got
812 versus 1012 on the horizontal
delta so it's not showing that here you
got 545 against 315.
obviously that's going to give you a
nice
supportive bid here you can see there um
you know the 395 against 258 so you're
seeing the the support of bidding coming
up so that if there's any selling coming
in as you're going up to these new highs
it's going to absorb whatever selling
there is
okay so that's you know that's one of
the ways you can see absorption coming
into the market as the market is going
up i mean absorption isn't you know this
nice neat thing where you can tie a bow
around it that happens at swing lows
um you know you're always looking for it
on moves right you want to see some
signs of absorption any counter trade
that's coming in you want to see that
being absorbed by traders right to stop
that move from going back down to where
it started
now a little bit later
it was just uh around 12
um
12 o'clock here this was interesting
this
push down here
and then this move back up right this is
a nice
bar down you know 22 and three quarters
down to 16
um then we rallied back up into the 20s
like 27 28. now
earlier you just had that a similar drop
from you know 22 down to uh 16 and a
quarter it's you know
it's almost the same size maybe exceeded
it by a point but what was interesting
on this move back up i mean here we got
this you know we started getting this
move back up a little bit this one was a
little bit more dramatic and faster
was what was happening inside these bars
here so you got the big negative delta
minus 800 then you get green bar green
bar negative delta negative delta
okay now in this bar you're seeing
selling and balance selling and balance
selling the balance on these green bars
so again this is also a sign of
absorption right because what you have
you have strong bidding coming in
as this market just dropped now the
bidders are coming in to say you know
what we just dropped from 22 down
to 16.
you know i think it's i think we should
be trading back up around 22. so they're
going to work bids in there to absorb
whatever selling's coming in
right and these bars obviously decent
volume 4 500 4200 and you just got small
negative delta so it's telling you the
trade is evenly matched they're still
sellers in there but they're still
buyers coming in you know buyers are
interested at these at this price at 16
16 17 even all the way up to 18 19.
right there's people interested in
buying it they're not they don't
necessarily have to come in and start
lifting all the offers because they know
that they're still selling coming in so
they're working these bids to absorb
whatever um selling is coming in
right then you see they start flipping
aggressive maybe some of these traders
that
got short on this big bar down or have
to flip and start being aggressive as
the market starts ticking back up and
start covering it you know that could be
one of the signs of um
causing these imbalances here you know
and then the market just rallied back up
from the 20 all the way up to um you
know 25 26 27.
so
hopefully you know this video will help
you guys understand you know how to use
delta to see absorption how to use
imbalances this is a sign of imbalances
recognizing absorption small deltas
start seeing small deltas take a look
further at what's actually going on in
the bar
could be a sign of absorption as well so
thanks for watching this video be sure
to subscribe to the channel and click
like on the video you know i love those
vanity numbers so thanks everyone bye
bye